If you want to find out how you can win this
Pennywise keychain, then stick around to the
end of this video.
The moment we’ve all been waiting for since
129 minutes into the first movie has arrived
-- and basically 12 videos and one terrible
song later --
“IT: Chapter 2.
Happy Death Day 2U.”
It Chapter 2 is here, so let’s take a look
at the Things You Missed.
The movie opens with a shot from the first
film: Beverly Marsh “floating” after being
abducted by Pennywise, which suggests that
this event has a greater significance than
we previously realized.
We later find out that because Beverly looked
into the Deadlights as a kid, she has the
ability to see things that the others can
not, which is hinted at in the last scene.
“I saw us, all of us together back in the
cistern.
We were older.
Like our parents ages.
I just remember how we felt.
How scared we were.
I don’t think I can ever forget that.”
We then see an extended version of that scene
where Stan the Man asks what he looks like
as an adult, and if you look at Beverly’s
reaction she looks sad for a moment before
lying to him, and saying he’ll be the same,
but taller.
We all know what happens to Stan…
No!
No, put that down.
We then flash forward to Derry in 2016, which
is the most modern depiction of the fictional
town that appears in many of Stephen King works.
The Derry Canal days festival is going on,
and three anti-gay teens harrass a couple:
Adrian Mellon and Don Haggerty.
The movie shows how Adrian ended up with the
“I <3
Derry” hat, which in the book, is the item
that sets Adrian’s attacker over the edge.
No pun intended.
The scene is also inspired by a real crime
that occured in the 80s while the book was
being written.
The way the three attackers act is very similar
to how Henry Bowers and his gang of bullies
behave in the first film -- and that may be
a clue about how the phenomenon of violence
that Mike Hanlon calls “the Derry Disease”
is now impacting a new generation of teens.
Mellon is thrown off the bridge, and Pennywise
secretly makes his first appearance in the
background for a brief moment while Mellon
pops up for air.
In the next scene we see Mike Hanlon hearing
the news of the crime over police scanners,
and I noticed a photograph of his Uncle from
the first movie.
The uncle takes over the role his father played
in the novel, so I think it’s reasonable
to assume that he probably passed away in
a similar manner during the 27 year gap, which
may be the reason Mike decides to stay in
Derry and investigate more about why bad things
happen so often in this town.
The next Losers Club member we meet is Bill,
who is on set filming a movie adaptation of
Attic Room.
In the novel, The Black Rapids is the name
of the book that gets made into a movie and
Attic Room is actually Bill’s first original
screenplay.
The change may have been made because each
of Bill’s stories represents one of his
experiences in Derry, and Attic Room would
have been inspired by the events at 29 Neibolt
Street, which are focused on much more in
the first movie.
They are shooting Attic Room on the Warner
Bros lot, and conversely, you can go to the
Warner Bros lot right now, you’ll see this.
It's almost as if they want people to go see
this movie...
The director is a real life director: Peter
Bogdanovich, likely just because the director
of It, Andy Muschietti, is a fan.
The next adult Loser we meet is Eddie.
You probably noticed that his wife, Myra,
looks exactly like his Mom from the first
movie, but if you haven’t read the book,
you might not get the joke.
Eddie realizes the woman he married is basically
exactly like his Mother when he finds an old
photo of his Mom.
“He looked from Mother to Myra and back
again to Mother.
They could have been sisters.
The resemblance was that close.”
The movie takes it a step further by literally
using the same actress for both characters.
In the new movie Eddie is a risk assessment
specialist for an insurance company, but the
fact that he gets in a car accident when he
receives the call from Mike Hanlon is a slight
nod to his limo driver career in the book.
After Richie, we meet Ben, who is now an architect.
He’s in a meeting with his associates where
he makes an argument for an open floor plan,
telling them, “if you throw up walls, it
feels like a prison, the point is to bring
people together.”
Whether he remembers it or not, the reason
he feels this way is because he’s felt the
power of unity before, when he and his friends
came together to defeat Pennywise.
“This is what It wants.
It wants to divide us.
We were all together when we hurt it.
That’s why we’re still alive.”
Ben also compares the office building to a
clubhouse, a hint that we would finally see
the clubhouse in the Barrens that was left
out of both adaptations so far.
When we see the exterior shot of Ben’s home
office, there is a turtle statue -- a reference
to the entity known as The Turtle in the book,
which is essentially the rival of It who gives
the Losers Club small helping hands along
the way.
The Turtle is referenced a few times in the
first film, and would be referenced again
later in Chapter 2, when a turtle can be spotted
on the desk during Ben's classroom scene.
The Turtle, like It, is a cosmic entity, and
on cue, the camera tilts up to the stars,
perhaps a hint that the interdimensional origins
of It will be further explained in this film.
The shot transitions into Stan’s living
room, where Mr. Uris is doing a bird puzzle
-- a little nod to Stan’s hobby in the book,
birdwatching.
Stan takes his life when hearing about It’s
return, and the blood dripping off of his
hand transitions to a leak dripping onto Beverly,
which is exactly what happened to Bill’s
drawing of Beverly in the first one, which
by the way, leaks in through three holes on
the ceiling -- and later in Chapter 2, the
three balls of light that represent The Deadlights
come down into the chamber from above.
At the end of this sequence, we see what happened
to Henry Bowers, and although we don’t see
how he survived the fall down the well, we
do see his arrest for the murder of his father,
and the guy who slaps the cuffs on him has
a name tag reading: Borton.
Chief Borton plays a pretty big role in the
book, namely, interrogating the father of
the Corcoran brothers after the death of one
and the disappearance of the other.
Adult Henry is driven into a mad fit of laughter
after seeing a red balloon floating outside
the asylum he now resides in, and is taken
to his room, where another connection to King’s
novel can be spotted in the background.
Near Henry’s bed in the room, there are
several pictures of the moon pinned up to
the wall, and I’m like 99% sure one of them
was the moon from Termina in Majora’s Mask.
But the reason for these moons is that in
the novel, It manipulates Henry by giving
him orders from what Henry perceives to be
a voice coming from the moon.
"Henry…
Henry BOWERS!"
So Zombie Patrick breaks Henry out of Juniper
Hills and later that night, the adult versions
of our cast are reconvening.
"This meeting of the Losers Club has officially
begun."
When Eddie is walking in he's in the middle
of explaining something to the waitress.
He says, "If I eat a cashew, I could... realistically
die."
The pause before he says those last two words
foreshadows the fact that Eddie is the next
character to kick the bucket.
The group gets to talking about Bill's career
as a writer and we find out that Attic Room
wasn't his first movie adaptation, a situation
that mirrors the scenario of adaptations of
It in real life.
The movie is telling us that this may not
be the first time that someone has decided
to tackle King's 1986 novel, but things are
going to go differently this time around,
especially with everyone Bill meets telling
him they love his writing, but he needs to
work on his endings.
When they eventually get around to talking
about It, the cycle of the monster is described
as an echo that comes back every 27 years.
I find this word choice interesting, because
one of the new forms that the creature takes
is a bat, and bats of course rely on echo
communication to get around.
The idea of a bats being one of the forms
is new for this version, although there is
a vampire form that Ben sees briefly in the
novel.
Mike tries to explain the horrors that have
gone down this past summer to the others,
and briefly mentions the name Lisa Albrecht.
Like Chief Borton, this is another subtle
reference to the expanded events of the book,
where It kills this young girl on the anniversary
of Georgie’s death to try to send a message
to Mike.
It manipulates fortune cookies, first to give
the clue about Stanley's death, then to use
their own fears against them, and we see that
the bat is one of these.
Richie gets the crawling eyeball with tentacles,
an homage to his fear of a horror movie called
"The Crawling Eye."
Mike's cookie hatches into a bird, a connection
to the giant bird that attacked him in the
book and a bird that attacked him in his crib
as an infant.
Beverly's spurts out blood, a reminder of
her bathroom sink that spouts blood that only
kids can see.
Then there's this mutated insect with a baby's
head.
This is a combination of Eddie's problem in
the book where he can't get rid of the crickets
in the basement, and the problem of Infertility,
all seven members of the Losers Club are unable
to conceive a baby as adults.
"Any little crumbsnatchers for you Richie?"
"No, none that I know of."
While everyone is still undecided on if they
want to stay and fight, It makes the next
move, luring a young girl from the bleachers
of a little league game using a lightning
bug, a form that again, could be connected
to deadlights.
The girl’s name, Victoria, is does not line
up with one of the victims in the book, but
may be a little homage to the original It,
the 1990 TV mini-series.
“Who are you.”
“I’m Vicky Burrows.”
The encounter is very similar to the Georgie
scene in Chapter 1, in that Pennywise lures
her in with something she wants, in this case
removing the scar from her face.
He says he’s going to do it on a count of
three, but the count ends after reaching 2,
much like how It Ends after Chapter 2.
That evening, Mike takes Bill to the library
and in the background there is a circus poster
with Pennywise on it, though it’s not clear
to me yet if that is part of It influencing
the town, or part of Mike’s research into
Derry.
I did spot a book that Mike had been looking
into on his desk; A History of Old Derry by
Branson Buddinger.
This is the same book that Ben checks out
in the library in the first one, and the author
is a character from the novel It.
Buddinger, who had died in 1950, was a historian
who Mike learns of from a former Derry librarian
who tries persuading Mike not to look into
Derry’s past.
After publishing the book, A History of Old
Derry, which exposed the violent pattern of
the town’s past, Buddinger was found dead
by his own hand, but like all of the tragedies
in this town, something prevents the story
from picking up significant news coverage.’
Another book that I noticed in Mike’s study
was called Pillar in the Sky -- it may be
in reference to The Dark Tower, a series of
Stephen King books that expand on the mythology
of deities such as the Turtle.
Mike has Bill perform the smoke hole ceremony.
In the book, the seven of them all do this
as kids, but only Richie and Mike have the
vision about the arrival of It.
But in the movie, Bill is able to see the
abstract vision of the three beacons of light,
which match what Beverly saw in the first
movie, and It which shapeshifts into a couple
different forms, such as Mike’s giant bird,
and the spider creature that they see at the
end.
After seeing this vision, and Beverly telling
of the nightmares she had of their deaths,
the group decides to stay and fight back against
It, and Mike takes them back to The Barrens,
where they come across their old clubhouse.
In the flashback, they wear surgical caps
while in the clubhouse to prevent spiders
from getting in their hair, to which Richie
asks if “they’re really going to be afraid
of spiders.”
In the end, overcoming their fear of the spider
form of Pennywise is how they ultimately defeat
It.
Mike gives them the mission to find the artifacts
of their past throughout Derry, during which
there are more flashbacks, like Beverly’s
abusive father covering her with her late
mother’s perfume.
The scene reminds me a lot of this one line
from the book, which Beverly describes her
dad’s increasing willingness to raise his
hands against her.
“It was as if there was a smell they made
between them, a smell that wasn’t there
when she was in the apartment alone, one that
had never been there when they were in it
together—not until this summer.
And when Mom was gone it was worse.
If there was a smell, some smell, then he
knew it too, because Bev saw less and less
of him as the hot weather wore on.”
Beverly goes back to her old apartment, where
Mrs. Kersh now lives.
She notices something is off when she spots
the holes on Mrs. Kersh’s chest, a lasting
injuring from where Ben stabbed the monster
with the fire poker 27 years ago.
Roll it.
"AHAHA!"
"AHHH!"
"Kill it!"
The next thing Beverly notices is the photo
of Mrs. Kersh and her fodder.
“My fodder joined the circus.”
...and aside from the familiar facial features
of this man, there’s also a familiar looking
trailer in the background.
The next flashback would come from Richie,
who revisits the old movie theater arcade,
where an interesting detail can be found.
The old movie theater has been closed down,
with the marquee now simply reading, “thanks
for the memories”,
"...even though they weren't so great!"
which is kind of a shame because they could
have put up posters for Warner Bros movies
from 2016 like Lights Out and The Conjuring
2.
But instead, there’s just an old left behind
poster for You’ve Got Mail, which tells
us that the theater probably closed in 1998,
nine years after the initial battle with Pennywise.
Also, this is the second Meg Ryan reference
so far, the first being Adrian Mellon telling
the bullies that “Meg Ryan wants her wig
back” in the opening.
Richie flashes back to a scene where he flees
from Henry Bowers and takes a safe haven in
City Center, where he is attacked by the Paul
Bunyan statue who has bats flying out of his
mouth, which explains the aforementioned fortune
cookie with the bat.
Then, in the present, Richie reads a flyer
for his own funeral, which is either a callback
to the missing poster from the first movie,
or the poster for Richie Tozier’s All Dead
Rock Show from the book.
Or both.
Could be both.
Meanwhile, Bill goes into a shop called Secondhand
Rose when he sees his old bike, Silver.
The shopkeep is none other than Stephen King
himself, which provides an interesting conversation,
given that Bill as a character is already
kind of an extension of Stephen King, it’s
almost as if King is having a conversation
with an older version of himself, something
that actually happens during the climax of
the movie during the Ritual of Chud.
King also has a copy of The Black Rapids -- the
fictional Bill Denbrough book I mentioned
earlier.
Bill tells the shopkeep that his old bike
was “fast enough to beat the devil”, and
the line is a direct reference to the chapter
title, “Bill Denbrough Beats The Devil”,
which is brought back as the tagline of the
book’s epilogue.
Next, Bill visits his old house, where a new
family now lives.
The son is a kid who rides a skateboard.
The bottom of his board displays the carpet
pattern seen outside room 237 in The Shining.
The skateboard kid does appear in the novel
briefly.
Bill tells him to be careful, to which he
replies, ‘you can’t be careful on a skateboard’,
a line that continues to come up in Bill’s
mind throughout the book.
In the movie, Bill tells him to be careful,
and the kid just looks back… maybe I’m
looking into it too much, but maybe this is
Muschietti telling us that things are going
to go differently from here on out.
And after seeing this thing, it’s hard to
say I can blame him.
Ben searches for his artifact back at the
high school.
“Neeeeerrrrrrrrrrdddddddddddddd!!!!!!!!!!”
He flashes back to a scene that took place
while the kids were back in school, after
this fight, but before defeating It.
It’s interesting how both movies added a
scene of It taking the form of Beverly in
order to trick Ben, as far as I can remember,
there’s nothing like that in the novel.
In this version however, before Ben kisses
her, she turns into a monster with a flaming
head -- I believe this is IT taunting him
about the poem he had written her, turning
the line “your hair is winter fire” into
something literal.
Also worth noting, this could be a reference
to another creepy clown, Sweet Tooth, from
the Twisted Metal franchise -- however I don’t
think it was intentional because the scenes
where Ben is a kid take place in 1989 and
Twisted Metal wouldn’t come out until 1995.
Also, Ben saves himself by locking himself
inside his locker, a scene that is very similar
to Creepy Clown School Lockdown: Epidemic.
I might need to have my lawyers look into
this one.
And perhaps even more suspicious than that,
is in the next sequence where Eddie stops
in to pick up his prescription at Center Street
Drug, they somehow have me in the background
browsing the aisles?!
Oh wait, that’s actually a cameo from the
director, Andy Muschietti, which completes
the trifecta of cameos: Bogdanovich, King
and Muschietti.
If you were wondering if the woman behind
the counter is Greta Keene, the same girl
who writes ‘LOSER’ on Eddie’s cast,
she’s still wearing the same necklace with
the letter G. Eddie’s flashback takes him
to a scene where he’s lured into the basement
of the pharmacy when he hears his mother’s
voice crying for help.
He looks behind the curtain to discover his
mother tied up to a chair with the Leper coming
for her.
Though this is only an illusion created by
It, he is unable to save her, but this is
a visual setup for when Eddie overcomes his
fear of the horrors that are beyond the curtain
later on as an adult, when he punctures through
the shower curtain to kill his attacker, Henry
Bowers.
When I covered the first movie, one thing
I pointed out was how Tim Curry’s Pennywise
from the mini-series adaptation of It makes
a small cameo in the clown room.
Chapter 2 continues that tradition when Bill
makes his way through the haunted house in
an attempt to rescue the skateboard kid.
These swinging clown pendulums share the yellow
suit, purple vest, parted tufts of red hair
and red rubber nose that can be found on Curry’s
Pennywise, whereas none of these features
can be found on the new design for Bill Skarsgård’s
Pennywise.
When he gets into the hall of mirrors, Pennywise
appears for less than a second in the background
during one of the strobes of light.
After being unable to save the skateboard
kid, Bill loses it and goes alone to the house
where they had encountered It so many years
before: 29 Neibolt Street.
Just like when Bill foolishly ran off to face
the threat alone as a child, his friends give
chase to come aid him.
They go inside, where they come up against
a bit of a bridge between something that happens
in the book and the second coming of something
that happens in the first movie.
In the first film, Pennywise comes out of
this fridge to attack them...
"Time to float!"
...and in the book, they are having a discussion
in the library, and It uses the form of Stan’s
head inside of a mini-fridge to taunt and
frighten them.
"Stan!"
"Sorry I'm late.
Well let's see who's here."
So when The Amazing Spiderstan comes out of
the fridge, it does a good job of bringing
those two worlds together.
The idea of someone’s head turning into
a spider, and the line that Richie says when
he sees it, is also a reference to John Carpenter’s
The Thing.
“You’ve gotta be ****ing kidding.”
We also see the H on Ben’s abdomen, that
Henry carved in the first movie, reappear,
this time spelling out the words: Home At
Last.
After another run in with the monstrous version
of Mrs. Kersh, who apparently didn’t get
the memo about It’s catchphrase.
“You’ll float too.”
No, not that one.
“You lied, and I died!”
No, the other one.
“Time to float!”
Yeah, that one.
They end up finding a manhole in the cistern
that leads them deeper into the sewers and
this is where they all must perform the smoke
hole ritual together, in scene that’s filled
with even more secrets.
The matches that Mike uses to start the fire
that begins the smoke hole ritual are from
Jade of the Orient, the Chinese restaurant
that they meet at for the reunion.
The Ritual of Chud begins, and this isn’t
a Thing You Missed, but I just feel the need
to point out I ****ing called it when I uploaded
this video on May 25th.
Roll it.
“I just think that they have to make a cooler
looking arachnid than the one from 1990, maybe
instead of a giant spider, it’s more of
a half clown, half spider alien hybrid.”
Now, I know what you’re thinking, I should
just mic drop and walk away.
But the mic is up there and I still have a
few more Things You Missed.
And I’m actually borrowing this mic at the
moment, I don’t really want to risk breaking
it.
The point is, you owe me a like on this video
or something.
But anyway, each of the Losers is thrown into
their own personal scenarios where they must
overcome Pennywise.
For Beverly, she torn into the bathroom stall
where she was bullied as a young girl, or
at least some version of it.
The word smokehole can briefly be seen written
on the wall, and the blood that nearly drowns
her is an extreme version of the blood that
came out of her father’s bathroom sink.
In the first movie, it’s a symbol for her
struggles with reaching the age of puberty,
but in this film, it’s more of a reminder
of the abuse she endured as a child, and this
is solidified by the fact that the characters
that poke their heads into her bathroom stall
are the three predatory characters that objectified
her, her father, the pharmacist and Henry
Bowers, who screams, “Here’s Johnny!”
as he pokes his head around the door.
“Here’s Johnny!”
I did a whole video on the connection between
The Shining and It, which you can watch here,
or find the link in the description at the
end of this video.
Eddie and Richie encounter the set of three
doors that terrified them in the first movie,
and behind the first one, there's a pair
of legs unattached to a body.
If you remember in Chapter One, Bill and Richie
open a door and see the severed upper body
of their missing classmate, Betty Ripsom,
so I think this kind of shows, that they are
in the inverse of that world.
I also found it kind of funny that they actually
didn’t get the same actress back for this
sequel, so the new actress is credited as
Betty Ripsom’s legs.
After everyone makes it out of their personal
battles with It, Eddie finds his bravery and
attacks the monster, which retaliates and
seriously maims Eddie, leaving a smudge of
clown makeup on his cheek.
It you look closely, you can see the word:
IT, though I probably don’t have the footage
for this, so you’ll have to go back and
see the movie.
When the Losers get an advantage over It,
the creature cycles among many of the forms,
and you can tell that It’s losing It’s
touch when it briefly takes the form of the
woman in the painting, which was Stan’s
fear, and he hasn’t been around since like
15 minutes into the movie.
To be fair though, that thing is pretty freaky
regardless of if you’re Stan or not.
After losing Eddie, the others are able to
come together and finally put an end to the
thing that has caused the horrors around Derry
for all these years, and they escape from
the Neibolt house just before it collapses.
This is a scaled down version of the way that
the book ends, where an epic flood destroys
Derry and symbolically purges all the evil
that had taken place there.
So this was the one thing I was a little disappointed
with for this movie.
That storm scene would have been wild.
But as I mentioned way back at the beginning
of this video, it was well established that
the movie was going to do something different,
because Bill Denbrough, who kind of represents
Stephen King, is criticized for his story
endings, by his wife, Peter Bogdanovich, and
basically everyone he meets along the way,
so his next book, that we see him writing
in the epilogue, has a more positive ending,
and It Chapter 2 follows suit.
The town is not destroyed.
The evil is conclusively vanquished.
And the remaining members of the Losers Club
don’t lose their memories again when they
leave Derry.
Bill Denbrough does once again, beat the Devil,
but this time, it’s a personal demon that
he’s overcoming.
The ancient evil that for so long haunted
Derry, was now gone… but you are still gonna
have a chance to have your own evil entity,
in the form of a keychain!
That’s right, I’m giving this thing away,
and here’s how you can be entered to win
it!
First, follow CZsWorld on Instagram!
Then find this post and leave a like!
The winner will be selected at random.
Full contest rules can found in the video
description.
I think I’m gonna be vlogging more horror
related events on the Instagram from now on,
so maybe you can even stick around and not
just unfollow me after the giveaway.
But that’s your call.
So that’s It.
Pun intended.
Of course there may be a few things that I
missed, so let me know what you might have
noticed in the comments.
I’ll probably do a follow up episode once
the movie comes out on Blu-Ray and I can really
dig deep for any details that went under the
radar in this video.
So make sure you're subscribed to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week, ring that deathbell
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
Assuming we both survive.